i don't worry about it you know i
understand where everyone's coming from
i understand where i'm at in my career
um but i also you know believe in
compartmentalizing things and focusing
on
you know what's in front of us this week
and the job that i have to do
we've got 11 ball games to go in this
season and we've got to find a way to
get some wins and
get back in the mix and that's you know
that's where our mindset has to be at it
has to be different
um you know from what everybody else is
is kind of talking about right now as
players
uh you know we can't control that all we
can control
is is our preparation and our
performances you know week in and week
out
matt ryan talking about his future with
the falcons the future that was thrown
into doubt earlier this week when
coach jan quinn gm thomas dimitrov both
fired and the next day arthur blank
saying
it's going to be up to the next regime
as to whether or not matt ryan stays
that's not my
decision look peter from a cap
standpoint i think their hands are tied
for 2021. uh
44 million dollars if you cut or trade
matt ryan that hits the cap now
the only argument that it doesn't matter
is that he's got a 40 million dollar cap
number if you keep him
so you're only talking about a net cap
charge of 4 million and you save
23 million if you move him off the
roster
but again it's all going to come down to
what the new coach and the new gm want
to do and a lot of times a new coach in
the new gm want that red shirt year
where they get to give the the the
current quarterback a test drive and
then move to their own guy
in the second year of the new regime
yeah i think i think it's probably quite
unlikely that they move on from matt
ryan next year but
i'll tell you it's very very strange to
look at the atlanta falcons
and to look at two of their last three
games
and have zero touchdown passes in two of
the last three games
that's that's just incredibly unfalcon
and so you know obviously they've got to
get better
but i do think the one other thing that
you consider when you talk about matt
ryan
is that he basically is he's the leader
of this team
on and off the field and i don't
think you want to make all of these
revolutionary moves
in one fell swoop i think matt ryan
comes back in 2021
and he basically plays for his future
you know with whoever the new coach is
that's my gut feeling i think it's the
same as yours
yeah i think that's right they are going
to have to do something about that cap
number though of 40 million dollars you
know we're now getting to the point
where these guys who have gotten the
huge contracts are getting into the
years of the contracts because they set
it up so the cap charge
early isn't all that dire they push it
out to the future years and they always
assume
by the time we get to that really big
number we'll work something out we'll do
a restructuring we'll kick the can we'll
extend the deal whatever if you're
dealing with a new regime
that may be a little ambivalent well
maybe matt's a little ambivalent one of
the things arthur blank said it's going
to be up to the player too and
you know if if a franchise quarterback
doesn't want to be with the franchise
anymore
it makes it hard to go forward and
they're going to have some decisions to
make and they're going to have some work
to do
to try to get that cap number under
control and if matt ryan is staying he
would presumably have an incentive to
get the cap number under control or he's
not going to have a very good team
around him but some big
decisions that they have to make as we
mentioned earlier the facility
of the atlanta falcons was closed on
thursday the sunday game against the
vikings is still
on at one point yesterday there was a
report that the falcons could have
actually gone into work yesterday
afternoon and they chose not to i guess
they just look and say we're on five
what the hell what what difference
what does it what it does if you think
it's gonna help us win this weekend
uh although who knows you know the
interim head coach thing
sometimes gives you a little bit of a
bump but this falcons team peter i don't
know it's just
for a team that finished six and two
last year just like the jets
jets and falcons finished six and two
last year hey keep an eye on them
for 2020 and they're a combined oh and
10 now
you know mike look if if you were the
atlanta falcons and i understand
that raheem morris is looking at this as
you know the same way greg williams
looked at it when he
took over the the browns with whatever
eight or nine games left to go
hey look this is my chance we are gonna
go
uh you know we're gonna go all out to
try to win
every game that we can so i get that
but i also think that one of the reasons
you do this when you do it
i mean and there's no question why i
think
both teams you know who've made coaching
changes now
early have done this they basically said
look we want
all the time we can to look at the field
of coaching candidates we want to make
sure that we are not
basically just spending three days
you know 24-hour days for three days
trying to figure out
who we want to interview and and how
we're gonna get in line like
you know look at what the carolina
panthers did with matt rule
you know they had researched matt rule
and mike it was to the point where they
called matt rule when he was on vacation
with his family
and said basically we want to be first
in line
we'll interview you right when you land
from the airport
you know and that's what they did by the
time the giants even woke up the next
morning
they wanted a shot at matt rule he had a
plane ticket to new york that morning
he had already had his agreement you
know with the with the carolina panthers
so
you know that is what i think this extra
time
does it gives you time to get your ducks
in a row for your coaching search
and what your record is the rest of the
year you know i i'm it matters to ray
morris and good
he's going to be really motivated to put
a great product on the field but the
rest of the organization
is going to have half an eye on that and
and
the other eye or one eye on that and the
other eye on hey
you think dabo dabo swinney will come
out do you think
you know they're going to be looking
into the things that are important for
the 2022
2023 falcons and not just this year
you know in 2018 when the packers fired
mike mccarthy with several games left
i think that helped crystallize this
idea
that it's in everyone's interest once
the team makes the decision it's not
disrespectful to the coach if anything
it's extra respectful you're not working
behind his back
you you're not holding him in place for
the next four weeks
in in a a a task he can't win at
he's still getting fired when it's all
said and done let him embark
on his next step let him take the next
four weeks to decompress so he can make
some good plans about what he wants to
do for the future
instead of telling him he's fired as
soon as he reaches the end of the
marathon that is an nfl season so i
think more and more teams are realizing
it
and they're doing it earlier and it
started with the texans it continued
with the falcons
and it makes me wonder will other owners
be more
likely to follow suit is that the
copycat trend this year where we see
multiple additional interim coaches on
top of the ones we've already seen
in atlanta a bit of a surprise that it
wasn't just the coach dan quinn it was
also
long time gm thomas de mitroff he was
hired way back in 2008 he appeared on
brother from another
yesterday and was asked among other
things did he see
his own firing coming
we were in a spot unfortunately with
with two losing seasons and and going
into an
0-5 that uh all
all bets were off quite honestly it just
depended on on how it was gonna play out
and in the end
uh you know mr blank decided that it was
best to go with uh
both the head coach and the general
manager at one time and
and focus on moving forward so again
never never going to be easy in that
situation but
uh appreciate my my 13 years there and
and
know that there's going to be some
really interesting beginnings
and and new journeys which i've always
been really excited about i'm not just a
myopic
uh football person necessarily there's a
lot in my life and a lot of layers that
i'm looking forward to digging into
doesn't necessarily sounds like he wants
to jump right in as a general manager
and peter the dynamic in the nfl
has been coaches will often get a second
bite at the apple
general managers for the most part you
get one shot
now dave gettleman ended up getting
another opportunity
um and then there are others that have
gotten second opportunities
but for the most part those are few and
far between it always seems like when a
team's looking for a general manager
it goes to the less experienced
up-and-coming
scout who's who's using all the new
the new tricks of the church douglas
grew up in a different environment yeah
yeah instead of somebody who's done it
before
and that's just kind of the way it is
and so i would bet against
a door opening somewhere else for thomas
dimitrov right away just because that's
not how it works
joe douglas chris berry uh chris berry
uh
or i'm sorry chris ballard andrew berry
to me i think when you look at guys who
get gm
jobs here is the way
that the average owner will think of
this
number one what team in the league is
winning right now
why do you think that the patriots have
been
a great little gm tree
for for for so many teams you know
you look at the lions and you i mean you
go back and look at the chiefs
taking scott pioli in 2009 i think it
was
and you go back and you look and you
basically say
gm's get jobs from winning programs
and when they have stories that are like
you know
joe douglas was the key guy in in the
ravens organization
to say listen just wait you can get joe
flacco in the middle of the first round
or maybe even later
and he's going to be our guy and
although
flacco turned out to have a bit of a
short shelf life
i mean he won a super bowl and so
and and played very very well in that
playoff run in that super bowl so
i know a lot of people were sort of you
know down on flocco near the end and are
down on them now but
forget that if if you're drafted i think
he was 18th overall
and you win a super bowl for the team
that drafts you throw a parade
that's a great draft choice so and joe
douglas was
primarily responsible for that when you
work for ozzie newsome eric decosta
and then you go and work for
philadelphia howie roseman and that
personnel staff
and have a lot of experience with a guy
with with
smart smart people that's who that's
what owners want so and i'm not saying
that's the only
uh way to get a gm job but those are the
that's where the questions really start
with the really good programs with guys
who've got a good pedigree
and one of the other realities too that
complicates the general manager hire if
the coach is in
charge of everything sometimes you have
to go outside the box to hire a gm
you can't just go and hire the up and
coming
director of player personnel from
another team because unless you're
giving that guy final
say in some respect of the draft the
roster whatever
his current team can say no and that's
why john lynch ended up with the 49ers
where kyle shanahan runs the show
that's why mike mack ended up with the
raiders where john gruden runs the show
it's one of the reasons why
because you can't just go to another
team and say we want that guy
who's the next the next potential gm
candidate
because if you're not going to let him
be a true gm uh
you're not going to get him away from
the team that currently has him so
a bunch of factors a bunch of issues but
i don't know what thomas is going to do
i respect
the hell out of the fact that he
survived there from 2008
until now uh and mike remember
remember two things remember two things
about dimitrov and i know people are
down
lately on his drafts and some of his
free agent signings
i get that and some of them deserve to
be criticized
but remember two things he resisted
all sorts of entreaties back in 2008 i
was in their draft
at their draft that weekend and i will
never forget
he had multiple chances to trade out of
the pick that became matt ryan
including a very serious
uh you know offer from the from the
ravens
you know later in that draft they ended
up later in that round they ended up
taking flacco
but early in that draft they were
contenders to move up
to try to get matt ryan but what what i
what i was going to say is there's that
and then the
real gutsy trade way up to get julio
jones
so to me to my way of thinking you know
when you talk about
the two most important players in that
franchise over the last decade
you know are matt ryan and julio jones
and thomas dimitrov
worked to make both of those picks
happen and to make both of those picks
right
so i understand that everybody is ticked
off that
they're five under 500 since they were
in the super bowl
that's not good but let's just remember
that the body of work is pretty good
with thomas dimitrov
and remember he contacted bill belichick
for his advice before pulling the
trigger on the trade up to get julio
jones and belichick told him
don't do it and he did it anyway that's
right gutsy move
by thomas dimitrov hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports